dude I had a really bad experience
recently at the weed store anybody
anybody had their card not you anybody
you have your card right just one person
has their card kiss you and you it's a
pot you guys people smoke weed raise
their hands a little later than the rest
of us don't they you smoke weed yeah
here's the deal I went into the weed
store and I had anybody had the edibles
okay so for those that you don't know
the edibles kind of [ __ ] you up I did
not know that so I went in now listen
something you need to know about me it's
like I [ __ ] love blueberry muffins so
I walk into the weed store and I'm like
are those blueberry muffins that guy was
like yeah and I said does that have weed
in it and he said yeah and I was like
I'll have a blueberry muffin
so my weed store has like a little area
where you can smoke and watch DVDs and
[ __ ] and I just put in Chapelle season
one [ __ ] great and I'm literally
licking my fingers when the guy runs it
[Music]
you didn't eat that whole muffin did you
huh tell me you didn't eat that whole
muffin right now all at once did you and
I was like yeah and he goes all right
listen and I'm not [ __ ] around right
now
either give me the keys to your car or
drive home right now and I see I said
what and he goes I'm telling you leave
here right now or prepare to be here for
8 hours it's like are you kidding me he
goes you ate that old muffin man he goes
I own this place
I would only eat half oh he was right I
was high for eight hours that's one of
those highs where you're like I have
kids man I had to pull one of these I
walked into the house I was like daddy's
sick don't come in the room click and
then I peeked my head I was like don't
no matter what you hear from this room
do not come in here it was bad it's
simply an hour later I was like except I
could use some orange juice